like many other people I'd read you know
Russian literature in Translation I'd
read War and Peace and you know I'd love
the book actually I mean particularly
the you know the story parts of it I
wasn't one really at that at that time
when I was a teenager I thought Telstra
went on a bit you know in terms of his
theories of the great man and of history
and you know kind of social change
though now I appreciate it more but when
I was about 14 I was like this man
needed an editor you know could you have
just gone on with the story but I'm an
amazing story what an incredible you
know kind of book this is I still think
he needs another book I think his wife
tried didn't you but um he got um he got
quite upset with her and then I kind of
thought to myself well how do I how do I
study Russian because there were very
few schools in my uh region you know
given the impoverishment of the region
where you could study Russian so I would
have to take Russian from scratch
and this is where things get really
quite interesting
because there were opportunities to
study Russian at universities but I
would need to have first of all an
intensive Russian language course in the
summer and I didn't have the money for
that
and the period is around the miners
strike in the United Kingdom in 1984.
now the miners of County Durham that
very interestingly had exchanges and
ties with the miners of donbass going
back to the 1920s
and as I studied Russian history I
discovered there was lots of contacts
between you know Bolshevik Soviet Union
the early period after the Russian
Revolution but even before that during
the Imperial period in Russia between
the northern England and the Russian
Empire and the old industrial areas
basically big industrial areas like the
northeast of England and places like Don
bass were built up at the same time
Often by the same sets of industrialists
and danetsk in the John bass region used
to be called husicka because it was
established by a Welsh industrialist who
brought in miners from Wales to help you
know kind of develop the coal mines
there and also the the steel works and
others that you know were gearing about
all the time and so I got very
fascinated in all these linkages and you
know famous writers from the early parts
of the Soviet Union like give Guinea
zamyasin worked in the shipyards in
Newcastle upon Tyne and there was just
this whole set of connections
and in 1984
when the miners strike took place the
miners of donbass along with other
miners from famous coal regions like the
roar Valley for example in Germany or
mine is in Poland
sent money in solidarity to the miners
of County Durham and they've been these
exchanges as I said going back and forth
since the 1920s formal exchanges between
miners you know the region the miners
unions
and I um heard again from the same uh
great uncle who told me to study Russian
that there were actually scholarships
with the children of miners it could be
former miners as well for their
education and I should go along to the
miners Hall Players called Red Hills
where the the minds of County Durham had
actually pulled all of their resources
and built up their own Parliament and
their own you know kind of players that
they could talk among themselves to
figure out how to enhance the welfare
and well-being of their communities and
they'd put money aside for education for
minors there was all kinds of lecture
series from the miners and all kinds of
other activities supporting soccer teams
and artistic circles and writing circles
for example people like George Orwell
you know were involved in some of these
writers circles in other parts of
Britain mining communities for example
and so uh they told me I could you know
go along and basically apply for a grant
to go to study Russian so I show up and
it was the easiest you know application
I've ever come across that just asked me
to my dad came along with me they asked
me to verify you know that my dad had
been a minor and they looked up his
employment record on little cards you
know kind of a little a little tray
somewhere and then they asked me how
much I needed you know to uh basically
pay for the travel and some of the basic
expenses for the um
the study and they wrote me a check
and so thanks to the miners of donbath
on this money that was deposited with
the miners of County Durham with the
Durham miners Association I got the
money to study Russian for the first
time uh before I embarked on my studies
at University as you're speaking now
it's reminding me that there's a
different way to look both at history
and a geography in the different places
is
um
you know this is an industrial region
that's right and it echoes in the
experience of living there
is more captured not by Moscow or Kiev
but by at least historically but by just
being a mining Talent industry that's
right in the place itself yeah yeah I
mean there are places in the United
States and Appalachia and West Virginia
and in Pennsylvania like the Lehigh
Valley that have the same sense of place
on the northeast of England you know was
the Cradle of the Industrial Revolution
it was the Industrial version of the
silica of Silicon Valley which has its
own
I would say Contours and frames and when
you come to those industrial areas your
previous identities get submerged in
that larger framework I've always looked
at the world through that lens of being
you know someone from the working class
the blue collar communities from a very
specific place with lots of historical
and economic connotations
and it's also a Melting Pot which is the
problems that the donbass has
experienced uh over you know the last 30
years that people came from all over the
place to work there of course there was
a population that one might say is
indigenous you know might have gone back
centuries there but they would have been
you know in the smaller rural farming
communities just like it was the same in
the northeast of England
and people in the case of the northeast
of England came from Wales they came
from further in the south of England the
Midlands they came from Scotland they
came from Ireland
um I have all of that Heritage in my own
personal background
and you've got a different identity
and it's when somebody else tries to
impose a den an identity like on you
from the outside that things go awry and
I think that that's kind of what we've
really seen in the case of Don bass it's
a place it's a part in many respects
historically and in terms of its
Evolution and development over time and
you know particularly in the case of you
know Russia uh the Russians have tried
to say well look you know because most
people speak Russia there is the lingua
Franca I mean in the northeast of
England because everyone spoke English
but lots of people were Irish speakers
you know garlic Irish speakers or you
know some of them might have um
certainly been Welsh speakers there was
lots of Welsh miners who spoke Welsh as
their first language who came there you
know but they but they created a an
identity it's the same in Belfast in
Ulster you know the northern province of
um of the you know the whole of the
Irish Island you know the part of
Ireland that is still part of the United
Kingdom that was also a heavily
industrialized area
um High manufacturing Mass manufacturing
shipbuilding for example people came
from all over there too which is why
when Ireland uh got its independence in
the United Kingdom
Ulster Belfast and that whole region and
I kind of clung on because it was again
that Melting Pot it was kind of
intertwined with the larger industrial
economy and had a very different
identity and so that you know for me
growing up in such a specific place with
such a
special in many respects Heritage gave
me a different perspective on things
when I first went to the Soviet Union in
1987 to study there I actually went to a
translators Institute what was then
called The Morris serez which is now the
Institute of foreign languages
um I was immediately struck by how
similar everything was to the north of
England because it was just like one big
working class culture that sort of
broken out onto the national stage
everything in northern England was
nationalized
we had British steel British coal
British Rail British ship building
because after World War II the private
sector had been devastated and the state
had to step in and of course the Soviet
Union is one great big giant
nationalized economy when I get there
and it's just the people's attitudes and
outlooks of the same people didn't work
for themselves they always worked for
somebody else and it had a quite a a
distortion on the way that people looked
at the world do you still speak Russian
I do yeah
it would be a big mystery for everybody
and you have an advantage on me because
your native language as well for people
wondering the the English speakers in
the audience you're really missing a lot
from the few sentences we said there
um yeah it's it's a fascinating language
that stretches actually geographically
across a very large part of this world